[Música]
la economía en directo américa de france
24 y louis 2008 en el estudio luis buen
día vamos a iniciar hablando de empresas
por el grupo automotriz estela anti se
anunció la paralización de actividades
así que es raúl es una situación que se
presenta específicamente la planta del
grupo ubicada en la localidad de desecho
en francia y esta suspensión de
producción se extenderá hasta el próximo
día sábado de acuerdo con un comunicado
de esta organización de acuerdo con un
representante del sindicato citado por
la agencia revista la escasez de chips
es la principal causa de la medida
tomada por la empresa con ellos serían
dos las empresas que se han visto
afectadas por la situación durante el
presente verano luego de que el
fabricante de vehículos peugeot se vio
forzado para realizar actividades por la
misma razón en una de sus plantas del
este de francia la escasez de
semiconductores ha sido un problema
recurrente en la industria automotriz y
su causa está asociada a la pandemia de
kobe 19 entre otras cosas por la
paralización de fábricas que producen
este elemento o cambios en las líneas de
producción la noticia de este lance se
presenta justo cuando la automotriz
japonesa honda anunció un recorte hasta
un 40% en su producción en la planta de
saitama previsto para el mes de
septiembre todo esto debido a problemas
persistentes en cuanto a la cadena de
suministro bueno y pasamos ahora a
hablar de eeuu porque en ese país
diversos productos rusos están llegando
a sus principales puertos una situación
en que revela la agencia de noticias ap
y se presenta en medio de que el
mandatario de la unión americana joe
biden había anunciado que iba a
infringir dolor y dar un golpe demoledor
a vladimir putin a través de
restricciones comerciales sí bien
productos básicos como vodka diamantes y
gasolinas se han visto limitados para su
llegada a eeuu de hacer empresa
descubrió que más de 3600 envíos de
madera metales caucho y otros productos
están llegando a puertos estadounidenses
desde rusia en fechas posteriores al
inicio de la operación militar especial
que comenzó en el mes de febrero si bien
los envíos registran una caída si la
comparamos con el año 2021 ave sostiene
que suman más
y millones de dólares en comercio por
mes la nota se presenta a la par de
otros artículos publicados por el ds the
washington post que señala un daño en
las sanciones en la economía rusa pero
que éstas aún no terminan de causar el
impacto que tenían en mente las naciones
occidentales al momento de
implementarlas entre los comentarios de
los analistas citados por la publicación
se señala que el desempleo no ha
aumentado notablemente y rusia continúa
ganando el equivalente a miles de
millones de dólares cada mes por las
exportaciones de petróleo y gas pero
hablando de exportaciones un artículo de
ape señala que el acuerdo monitoreado
por turquía y la onu para el zarpe de
embarcaciones con gran su craneanos le
ha generado beneficios también a rusia
en el sentido que el pacto le permitió
exportar toneladas de trigo que estaban
atrapadas en parte por las sanciones
impuestas bueno louis vamos a pasar al
reino unido porque esa nación culpa ese
objetivo de dejar la dependencia de gas
y petróleo ruso así es raúl de acuerdo
con la oficina de estadísticas
nacional es la nación dejó de importar
por completo petróleo refinado crudo gas
y carbón desde rusia durante el mes de
junio esta situación se presenta por
primera vez desde que comenzaron los
registros de la oficina de estadísticas
en el año de 1997 el ejecutivo del
todavía primer ministro boris johnson
cumplió antes de lo previsto su objetivo
de acabar con la compra de petróleo ruso
que se pensaba podría llegar antes de
fin de este año también las
importaciones de gas natural liquado
fueron determinantes para ponerle fin a
la compra por parte de rusia y en total
los bienes rusos que importaba el reino
unido- han caído alrededor del 96 6% en
2021 antes de la invasión aunque han ya
rusa era el mayor proveedor de petróleo
refinado del reino unido- y sus
importaciones representaban alrededor
del 24 1% también enviaba el 5,9 por
ciento del crudo y el 4,9 por ciento del
gas que utilizan los británicos las
sanciones establecidas por el gobierno
de londres llevado a las compañías
importadoras a buscar fuentes
alternativas según constata la oficina
nacional de estadística en cuanto a los
incrementos de compra de combustibles
desde arabia saudita a países bajos
bélgica y kuwait las importaciones
totales de bienes desde rusia han caído
en junio hasta 33 millones de libras
esto es equivalente a unos 39 millones
de euros también es la menor cifra en
cuanto a los registros modernos y
representa un descenso acelerado de las
tarifas adicionales y restricciones que
ha impuesto el ejecutivo louis y pasamos
a venezuela porque se depreció la moneda
en curso legal vigente de ese país el
bolívar y es que el valor del dólar en
el mercado paralelo en venezuela se
disparó debido a varios factores que
influyeron entre ellos el pago de bonos
a miles de empleados y maestros que
coincidió con la ausencia de ofertas de
visas por parte del banco central de ese
país el dólar
se incrementó hasta abrir una brecha de
casi 30 puntos porcentuales con respecto
a la oferta de la divisa por parte del
banco central el precio del dólar
paralelo escaló desde un mínimo de 6,2
bolívares hasta un máximo de 6,5 por
unidad durante la mañana del lunes y
llegó este miércoles a los 85 bolívares
por la tarde de las casas de cambio en
cúcuta llegaron a cotizar esta moneda en
10,2 bolívares la página web del banco
oficial también reflejó un incremento y
sitúa la cotización oficial en 70
bolívares por unidad siendo la primera
vez que supera la barrera de los siete
últimos indicadores económicos luís raúl
en las acciones globales subieron este
día jueves mientras los inversionistas
esperan el discurso del presidente de la
reserva federal de eeuu sobre las tasas
de interés previsto para finales de la
presente semana en asia los principales
mercados registraron en ganancias a lo
largo de la jornada todo ello por el
buen ambiente que se vive y la
expectativa que hay en torno a lo que
pasará con él y estadounidense
entretanto en europa también los
mercados están operando con números
positivos donde se registran leves
ganancias en los principales mercados
cifra el día tiene que ver con los 19
mil
410 millones de dólares que sería el
valor del presupuesto de taiwán
destinado a gastos de defensa para el
próximo período fiscal esto representa
alrededor del 14% de incremento si se
compara con el del año anterior louis
como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica pasamos a ser
lugares mares a que nos tiene toda la
actualidad deportiva